you know I got a new bit about seeing a
couple [ __ ] in the hotel room across
from me
did you yeah so I won't do the bit but
I'll tell you the story which is
basically New Year's Eve in Portland the
hotel is like a horseshoe shape so I'm
on the tenth floor and I look across
into a room and the curtains are open
lights are on chick is on her back legs
up and this dude who's ripped is [ __ ]
hounding her and I'm just standing there
looking at him like like this is the
greatest thing I've ever heard this is
great things ever happened I got I slept
my bag in my hand and I'm just
transfixed and he keeps [ __ ] I'm like
high-fiving the glass like go man and
then and so I had the curtain closed
because I didn't want them to see me but
I pop my head through the curtain from
the 1930s and then I start thinking
about what it must sound like and this
where it gets creepy creepier is I leave
my room I walk down the hall and I stand
outside the room and I listen and I hear
him grunting and I hear her go so I go
back to my room and I call the room no
just watching them waiting waiting he
didn't pick up but if he did I would
have been like
[Laughter]
[Music]